Jesus Christ man who got angry over
there they didn't like the Memorial Day
weird did you screw it on tight no or
maybe I did if it falls again I'll be no
it's two warehouse girls got them all
right guys this story here has just just
has me very perplexed perplexed will
happen this couple named Justin and
Alexis they had planned to get married
in Colorado Springs this month in May
Congrats they gave a $1,800 deposits for
their videographer who's a Dallas based
company and but tragically in February
the bride died in a car accident
oh I thought it was Corona related no in
a car accident before the cold ferrata
thing it was a control only way to roast
that bride then you gotta turn you got
her whole family it was just a good fun
pretty good right and then so like a
week later a couple weeks later that's
when the groom was going around trying
to get refunds for the wedding
obviously there's not gonna be a wedding
anymore and so when he hit up hey this
is [ __ ] I get a refund right because
my wife is dead or like well she's not
my wife yet oh yeah my fiancee I saw
this yeah yes yeah tell us the rest
please
right right okay so then he kept trying
to hit up the company trying to
like get his refund fulfilled like
whatever and so he like the company just
would not respond to this guy at all
specifically the videographer company
yeah the videographer company so the
Rose Company hit a mob like everybody
else hit him back up yeah except for the
videographer everyone else is like oh
man this is horrible yeah here's your
refund a decent deejay was like man I'm
sorry man yeah all right
DJ's always talk Cole so okay well
actually like they had responded I guess
saying that they will not refund cuz
it's this oh they did respond they
signed a contract in the contract
clearly states it's a non-refundable no
matter what like yes y'all are heartless
pieces right so then after you know four
months trying to like come on and give
me the refund kind of thing and they
just went like dark on him no refunds no
yeah so then he reached out again
letting them know that he planned to
tell his friends about what happened and
like posted on social media because he's
just like come on man
[ __ ] but before he could even do that
that's when they the company the
videography company got back to him and
said that they will sue him and her
family and because they were responding
to this review that the bride's mom had
written on the not website which is like
a wedding vendor website and and so they
that's what they were saying like we're
gonna sue you guys for what you said in
this review well it's not slander it
actually happened and are they on an NDA
exactly and I actually don't know what
the mom wrote oh yeah I don't know what
that happened there so then at that
point that's when the groom decided to
reach out to a local television station
and talk about what happened so then Oh
story was published on the website and
like with the Facebook post - oh I love
it
that's when this media company decided
to have a little comment well first of
all this is the couple oh they were
and then this is what they post or
should I feel bad okay noise it's [ __ ]
up yes okay now this is the media
company the video company birthday
posted they posted their picture and
then they posted the picture and they
said today would have been the day where
we would have filmed Justin and Alexis's
wedding in Colorado Springs after what
Justin pulled with the media stunt to
try and shake us down for a refund
we hope you sob and cry all day for what
would have been your wedding day
sorry not sorry shaking us down this
[ __ ] is such a [ __ ] prideful
idiot he thinks he's getting extorted
mm-hmm yeah I thought we were petty
that's Betty as [ __ ] guys the petty guy
level petty dude kill him he's a petty
peddler not only that not only did he do
that
what is [ __ ] I hate this guy they
actually went as far as creating an
entire cut entire website called
Justin's Montney calm which is the
groom's name oh and then they posted
this on that website and says
allegations would you like to read it
Wow okay yeah oh wow they picked such a
bad fish I know it's from his college
martyr you yeah this is really scary
photo but then he was like getting
worried for his safety and sure cuz like
they found like his college they've got
their copper stallion media a wedding
videography company signed a legally
binding contract between Justin Montney
and his fiancee on November 29th 2019
the fiance was killed in a car accident
on February 4th 2020 on February 17th
Justin reached out by email to tell us
that the wedding was off due to the
death of his fiancee we replied and
express our sympathy and explain to him
that all of our wedding contracts are
non-refundable
he kept emailing us trying to get a
refund and we kept reiterating that the
contract is non-refundable
we eventually stopped responding since
the issue was moot
for that using his likeliness [ __ ]
crazy yeah they were accusing him the
groom of fueling a smear campaign when
they're little keep doing the same thing
[ __ ] creating an entire this is one
of those people that take everything so
literal and they're like no exceptions
right it was like dude that's why your
business son it's horrible for your
business yeah mine dude it's horrible
right so they're saying like you know
according to this website but they
created that the vendor hundreds had
received more than 75 one-star reviews
on Yelp and the not in a matter of hours
since that story was published and he
thought he was gonna get it one on his
side of course cuz he has a stupid
friend who's like that's sick man oops
that [ __ ] it is not right that people
can go online and trash a company the
contract was non-refundable it will
never refund Justin money even with the
online threats and harassment if we knew
he was going to shake us down we would
have charged a higher deposit bug it's
1,200 bucks dude 80 yeah like imagine
how much business are gonna lose as a
result of it like how this guy's like
it's on the contract everyone should
understand a contracts a contract and
then on top of that he's like what if
all of my clients started dying oh yeah
what if I let this guy go everyone's
gonna think I what don't let them go if
they be on phase dies and that could
happen with the coronavirus you know
I'll go out of business well this guy's
a [ __ ] idiot it turns out that
apparently she didn't die Oh blood twist
apparently this this company's account
on the knots and wedding wires web sites
they were created under a false identity
by a man named Jesse J Clark okay and
that's the reason why because of the
fact apparently that it was a false
identity that's the reason why it was in
violation of its terms
so then they shut down those pages hmm
like those accounts so it turns out that
this Jessie J Clark we don't know if
it's the same guy but it clearly sounds
like it is back in 2013 he was accused
of scamming more than 90 couples out of
payments for wedding videos that were
never delivered in Massachusetts enough
to Dallas and start another wedding scam
but he's fun it's so funny to you I'm
not gonna be scammed I scam people here
he's hardly prideful about it he goes no
no you're not gonna scam me man you
can't scape a scammer yeah after he
essentially fled Massachusetts with a
number of warrants
oh he's [ __ ] and they're saying that the
state attorney general had an order
against him and that he was no longer
able to do business in Massachusetts and
that's the reason why he's lied and
apparently he still owes for clients a
hundred thousand dollars what pattern
interesting where I'm like if you're if
you're really doing all this guy why
would you create these websites in the
same name like copper medallion they
really like Jessie J whatever right yeah
because that was the same identity that
was behind the cloppers family because
he wasn't Dallas now he feels like
locally but dude nobody would have known
if he didn't wasn't such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah like he pissed number two started
already it sounds like he doesn't even
have the money anymore so yeah the story
went nationwide probably something nerd
got [ __ ] pissed and just dubbed into
everything and then expose this [ __ ]
like oh he's so stupid go nerd [ __ ]
nerds are pretty cool sometimes ya get
nerds not just for beating up I guess
the guy he just wants his 1800 but
nobody has to keep reliving this [ __ ]
like saying like my wife or my fiance
knows that [ __ ] made a website just to
spite him and the Facebook post is not
stood right so foul will be so thankful
today when she's dead our business check
out our business we do yeah yeah I hope
you cry all day today but check
you'd like this kind of posts we can
shoot your wedding to you guys we honor
contracts does he think a bunch of
people come out of the earth like oh my
God we're so glad you made front of that
bride dying kind all right so this guy's
no-nonsense he said what he thinks dude
really man that's exactly like their
country now like that's literally the
reality for idiots people get heart
would [ __ ] like that
words like yeah have a heart buddy well
a lot of cons just keep moving around
and they you know [ __ ] keep pulling
[ __ ] like this there's a lot of people
just trust people yeah change your name
at least go to a different country
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you